in five four three two one
what I need to be closer is this a good
that's that's way closer to your mom why
it the closer the better
okay yeah Jo push it away I'll try to
push that [ __ ] away there it is okay
there it is
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast I'm
your host David so and I'm your other
host on Thursdays Jo Jitsu kala and
today we have my beautiful as girlfriend
oh wow Jessica call well hottest [ __ ]
and all the [ __ ] Texas and [ __ ] I
don't know the hottest she's the hottest
[ __ ] in East Texas East Texas South
Texas South Thank You South Texas one of
the the newer additions to the JK family
I know right yeah wait you've never had
a you net yeah we never podcast okay she
came on mine I'm getting my Jamali radio
mixed up with you I've never had her on
I have I have a thousand million
questions for you specifically a lot is
the one the one thing that I wanted to
talk about the day I actually didn't
expect for you to be on the podcast but
then I was like oh it was last minute
yeah so a lot of people don't know so
number one when people develop
friendships people always think that it
things just happen to click all the time
yeah really fast right but I think that
one of the things that people didn't
realize was how hard it was for you to
uproot your life and come to LA you know
people just thinks that it's just plug
and play plug and play and a lot of the
times it's not I think specifically for
you that I number one I thought was
really brave of you because I don't know
if I would haven't been able to do it
was you literally I feel like you just
said this is my old life delete boom on
came to a committed she's crazy she's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] which new life yeah
it was definitely really easy to make
the decision but once the decision was
made and I was in the middle of it it
got really hard and like really
emotionally it kind of hit you when you
got here yeah yeah you were catalyzed by
this Japanese sausage
so city so said Jesus I think I think I
think for both of us to utilize by this
Texas [ __ ] bratwurst Texas peach Isis
brisket flats there's nothing no brisket
flaps there's nothing good to say for
Texas is there the pastrami [ __ ] taste
the Texas toast yeah shout out the
Whataburger yeah I think for both of us
it was it was almost like a shocker cuz
we both were just like [ __ ] let's do
it right but yeah most people talk
things through and create set up
expectations and did what was it I mean
it's been like five years now I don't
remember I all I remember was yeah okay
so this is the plan that we made more
plans for the road trip that we did for
our future yeah I think most of the
plans for our future Joe is like so
you're gonna come live with me and then
we're gonna have sex all the time
[Laughter]
let me tell you something you gonna get
this dick on a daily dose yeah
like shoot videos and then we'll just go
make a [ __ ] yeah vacations are [ __ ]
that's why it did not turn out like that
at all that's crazy we didn't land like
adults like you're supposed to talk [ __ ]
out you're supposed to do like you know
like like oh you know what are we gonna
do for work and all this stuff we just
kind of went in and then there was all
there was a lot of [ __ ] that was like
whoa I think like in the beginning
everybody's like that though that's the
passionate stage like all you see is the
goggles you know all you could see is
that pink film over your eyes and
everything is pink and beautiful
Emirates it's kind of crazy like I like
I can even remember that Mario said the
[ __ ] funniest thing when we first
going out specifically because I was her
first serious relationship but I
remember we were laying in bed and she
looks at me and she goes oh by the way
we did not have sex we were just laying
in bed and she looks at me she goes I
don't know what we'll ever fight about
and I've lost it up laughing her face
I started cracking up and she was what's
so funny and I'm like she doesn't know
it's like you don't know I said we're
gonna fight about the dumbest things you
have no idea and then when we finally
had our first
she goes oh my god I'm we're fighting I
was like yeah I told you it's about
nothing it's about the dumbest [ __ ]
[ __ ] like I probably spread my butt
cheeks and farted in a weird way and
you're just like oh that's gross now
that we means gross it's me yeah do you
hate me and then we just started
fighting about [ __ ] and I think that's
the part that we don't ever prepare for
and I feel like you guys did it fast
mm-hmm it seemed kind of it didn't seem
like that because you guys were long
distance at first right a year yeah
because you didn't move in with meri
until how many years cuz we both kind of
yea met you know our partners at the
same then on the same year yeah you
started dating Mary Oh around the same
time I started dating Jesse almost
around these that's right yeah but you
guys dated for a while before you made
the commitment to move and y'all didn't
have sex for a while too right yes yeah
so you got time to like work a lot of
things Oh burn burn do you we booked
like immediately crazy we talked for a
month well I used to talk man a day for
hours yeah yeah yeah I mean I guess like
for for me and Mariel we had this kind
of long-distance relationship because
she lived in Culver City and I lived in
k-town I mean I know it doesn't seem
like a lot but it's like an
hour-and-a-half Drive every time I would
go see her you know so you know for me
three hours out of my day wasn't
something that I could afford so we
didn't see each other a lot and I
actually I first thought that our
relationship was better because of that
which at first it was because of that
slow burn but at the same time we
actually fought more because of it
because we had to always solve our
problems through text mmm you know
that's the worst it's the worst yeah you
should never fight over text yeah and
then at a certain point too when you
when you fight over text you'll you'll
say something in text and you'll argue
the meaning of it and because you do it
so often you almost think that the other
person is lying sometimes just like
you're just doing that so you can get
out of trouble and that's what was
happening to us because I would write
something and you know I wouldn't put a
smiley face I wouldn't have an
exclamation mark and it would be the
interpreted as oh why are you mad at me
and then really I'm just taking a [ __ ]
and I'm just writing it because I'm
trying to wipe my ass or something you
know and it was very simple and basic
but I I started to realize that I needed
that face-to-face interaction thing cuz
oh yeah that's important when when when
we started spending more time together
like with each other it would
be the same conversation not in text but
with each other but the meaning was so
different it would be some [ __ ] like hey
are you hungry it's like not really cool
but if I wrote that in text not really
period it's like God what the [ __ ] dude
well [ __ ] you then exactly and it was
happening a lot that's interesting
because you know what I feel like we got
along better on text than we did in
person really yeah yeah why is that so
that's why it turned into like an atomic
bomb when we moved in together I think
we're both released this is this is my
conclusion from all the years I think
that we're both actually very sensitive
toward our partners like their tone of
voice what they say whatever [ __ ] face
like the look yeah yeah the physical
like how they carry themselves all that
stuff like so if I'm like irritated
it'll affect her vice-versa right so mmm
we never had that over text it's just
it's just like she gives me her message
but it doesn't have the sad face or it
doesn't have the the bad body posture or
it doesn't have the back communication
body communication that I might
misinterpret right it's just she just
gives me the message and I just read her
pure feelings through the message so I
didn't ever fight with her because we
connected a lot in that way like
whatever I thought she just got it
but then in person it's like this is
what she really meant but it didn't come
out like that in the physical mm-hmm and
that would all that would happen a lot
where I I misinterpret what she was
saying because I'm not reading her right
so millennial right [ __ ] over text
better then then we are over in person
that's [ __ ] crazy like I wouldn't
have thought about that and every time
we see each other like we're basically
playing we're adventuring we're eating
different foods we're going hiking doing
something fun so like there wasn't much
we were long distance yeah like those
those few weekends those few hours yeah
we kind of had together they were like
exciting because we'd waited weeks to
see each other so all of our moods and
everything we're great we were some ways
presented each other with the best but
yeah moving in it's like there's no
longer this like oh I'm cute texting or
whatever
and then you actually get to see me wake
up in the morning and go like nah I'm
not hungry yet or whatever you know and
just have that bad energy so we just
immediately stopped getting along yeah
also like we stopped texting and just
talking throughout the day so we didn't
have time to miss each other so we were
living with each other and it's like I
see you and then you know like as soon
as you move in with Mario like you know
that there's no escaping the fight if
something goes wrong you gotta either
face it or whatever right so I suck with
conflict resolution so like if if [ __ ]
went down like it just went down and
lingered yeah and and I was living with
it and I didn't know what to do with it
that's the crazy part when when your
partner is always around at home bases
her home base like there was this part
where Mary oh my god I just told the
story earlier where Marilyn I got into
this huge argument and we parlament into
maybe one fight since we moved in
together and then I I literally grabbed
packed my [ __ ] like a five-year-old
you know I might as well just put my
toys and my diapers in their [ __ ] and I
grabbed my [ __ ] and I looked at her and
she looks at me and she goes what are
you doing and I'm like I'm home what do
you mean she was
I can't run away I'm home yeah like I'm
here you're here I got nowhere to go
yeah and I started freaking out I was
like oh [ __ ] like what am i packing my
back so I'm a walk out the door and come
back in like I know where to go yeah my
Honda Element no no what I do what we
got into a really bad fight one time I
packed up some [ __ ] I put my dog's
leashes on and then we went stayed at a
hotel cuz I had to run the [ __ ] away Wow
yeah act up and I went to a spa or went
to the office and slept in my tatami
room there are times like I I just
slowly I think it's cuz I can't go to
sleep knowing that something's wrong so
with with I think that's the one
blessing that I have because I saw my
parents always do this so mind you my
parents would have [ __ ] catastrophic
fights catastrophic like I talked about
this earlier to where I remember my mom
throwing a loaded rice cooker at my
dad's head like straight up chucked it
and I know the exact tile piece that
cracked off and it's still glued there
till this day and my mom that acts like
I didn't I wouldn't know she goes you
know how do you remember
they fought so much oh yeah that's how
much fighting they did they forgot
something yeah and I told her I was like
dude you threw a rice cooker at his head
who the [ __ ] would forget that but what
I always noticed was that at the end of
the day at night they would always make
up and then they'd fight against Allah
but at least they always resolved their
problems before they would go to sleep
they never went to sleep angry and if
they did it was over it would be over
some crazy [ __ ] see that's why it's so
important to see parents resolve
conflict right yes I don't know how to
[ __ ] do it she doesn't you know we're
both from broken homes right so like I
don't even know to recognize that there
was a problem even though there was I
would I mean I or even if we know that
there is it's like what do we do with it
and then you try different things to fix
it and and it's like maybe your method
is even wrong - yeah well you know when
we were kids - like I didn't realize how
much like there's something I realized -
later on you know cuz when I was losing
weight well my dad used to like beat my
ass or I would get in trouble the next
day he would always like try to fix it
with food like he would always hear I
mean who does healing yeah so he would
heal yeah so then I started thinking to
myself yeah maybe that's why like you
know when I'm stressed out or some [ __ ]
I want to eat something because after I
got my ass beat the treat was uncommon
feet of it you know I think my dad when
he would he would I think about it now I
think I thought he would kick my [ __ ]
ass he would feel so terrible yeah you
know so he's just like I gotta make this
guy sandwich like a sandwich or
something instead of just emotionally
fixing it with you he's fixing it
through food yeah we had this huge talk
this is actually the last fight I got on
with my dad it was like three years ago
and we I got to a point where he said
something that really pissed me off and
you know mind you we don't fight that
much anymore but he was I yeah if it
wasn't for me you wouldn't be where
you're at and I got gonna trigger
something and I looked at him as like
what do you mean and he goes well he
goes well I supported you since day one
and I was like no you didn't I say you
absolutely did not you know and then we
kind of got into this huge argument and
then he goes whoa so what do you have
against me and I was like I was like
imagine if you would have just supported
me the
way you were like how you're saying you
didn't know and how how much further I
would be in my career you know for my
dad that kind of hurt his feelings a lot
cuz in his mind he thought he was doing
the best and so like when we had this
huge like braking moment and this is our
with our last huge fight
we actually I had a moment to understand
my father a little bit because that's
the first time he actually started
crying in front of me
Wow I've seen him cry oh and my brother
but he's never cried over me that man
because when I told him I was like I was
like you should say you [ __ ] up cuz
you [ __ ] up like you did I was like I
was like a mom supported me I was like
when you were yelling at me and
screaming at me mom told me hey just
graduate college and I'll support you no
matter what you do but just get this
degree for your dad so he gets off your
back I said but I didn't I don't even
think you knew about that conversation I
was surviving just because mom would
just she would push me like hey you can
do this you can do this but while you
were telling me I was stupid every day I
had somebody else supporting me you know
for him he was in his mind what I found
out was I was a [ __ ] I had to realize
that too I would I had such anger issues
and you know albeit I got it from him
too but he doesn't know why I'm punching
[ __ ] while breaking stuff in the [ __ ]
house he just sees it as your
troublesome because you don't listen
exactly and for him he just thought yo
my younger son is not like my older son
who's getting really good grades doesn't
even curse doesn't doesn't do any other
stuff so what I need to do is make sure
that he has a future so he would always
have me work at the store 24 [ __ ] 7
and the reason why is cause he was
scared that I was gonna end up homeless
okay so he wanted you to learn the
business so then you have something
that's my failsafe Dan but he didn't
tell me that you know but he he's trying
to mr. Miyagi yeah [ __ ] wax all like
what am i doing a slave working [ __ ] no
like because my brother would go on
field trips he would do everything else
but every Saturday I was at the store
working but now it turned out it works
out because now I understand all right
you know how to be an entrepreneur yes
okay okay mr. Miyagi my ass he did do
something right you know and it's kind
of crazy like looking at these things
that having those type of parental
influences because I know for you to
your dad bounced yeah and then your your
mom bounced as well so it's like I went
when I saw your guys's relationship
sometimes I thought like whoa it's very
hard how when both of you have like this
broken idea family tried to come
together and you guys trying to create
and that's so [ __ ] difficult and yeah
he didn't think about that until we got
older and now I look at Muriel and I was
like this is how my dad used to say to
me yeah he goes when you get with the
girl try to see what her family's like
it I'm like you [ __ ] terrible human
beings are the same thing yeah I think
you're not marrying her you're marrying
her family yeah and her family's [ __ ]
awesome thank people my family's awesome
were the [ __ ] back like we're the poison
in the family no it's just the other
half because it's just me and your oil
and vinegar that's what it is cuz you're
not a bad person
I'm not all what I said we just don't
mix that well oil is what I think you
guys Oaks we're two the same you guys
are oil and oil and oil and your
personality is a [ __ ] match that's
what it is because it's easy to point
out the differences like oh you're
organized and I'm chaotic and this and
that core values and what we find you
know what we agree upon like morals and
honor and a lot of things we're just
like that and when we first met like
those are the things we connected on the
important things and it's like it was a
breath of fresh air like I can't believe
I finally found someone that believes
the same things that isn't a [ __ ]
idiot
I could have a strong conversation with
like we could go from full of Safa coal
all the way down to sexual like whatever
like we could talk about everything and
um those are the things you take for
granted because it's there and it's so
easy but the things that stand out the
most are the differences yeah but
they're not really differences right
like because the difference is that you
guys have our normal couple differences
you're messy you're sloppy that stuff
but I think from how I see number one
just how I seen you guys argue you guys
are the exact same [ __ ] person and
that's where you guys clash a lot yeah
we don't clash over things like that
though like you're messy here what
exactly I do fight over like the toilet
seat down or whatever like it's never
that it's it's really just communication
like I don't like the way you spoke to
me hmm
so there's something weird and both of
us were like we just don't speak to each
other in a good way yeah but there's
never anything wrong being said it's
just like the emotions yeah we both are
kind of mean speakers you know like
that's anyone else I feel like and I
don't know what's because you
very close to his heart so all the small
things that you say and I've learned
this is with Muriel too like this is me
to her
it's he could he could be cold as much
as he wants to the rest of the world but
he'll never be that way to you which is
a good thing actually it's just you know
how biggest is fire and how much it
burns you right so the thing is it's
like if I was some random [ __ ] and I
told Joe about his dirty habits who the
[ __ ] cares like he's an idiot you'll
move on from it but you're somebody
that's like this with him so when you
say something small it's gonna spark
something bigger than anybody else well
the people that are closest to you are
the ones that could hurt you the most
yeah and so for you like I know like
sometimes when you guys fight it feels
like man like I don't know if this guy's
in my corner but the reason why things
happen like this because he's so in your
corner everything you say hurts them
because nobody else can do that to him
who else we've literally were on JK news
people say we say the craziest [ __ ] he's
just like right over your head as soon
as I come on JK knows and I like make
jokes just like Buster did [ __ ] sorry
I even got angry at her because she made
fun of the way I squeeze lemons I love
that you tell this story all the time
and then this is the thing that we do
you tell the same stories all the time
and then I get upset and this is this is
it this is it right here you never heard
of it I never heard the lemon story it
was like four years ago but that's just
how funny yeah like when I look back
it's just funny yeah I got another limb
is there okay so check this out long
story short right uh-huh I'm [ __ ]
squeezing lemons uh-huh and she's trying
to be funny and and and she's just like
that's how you know when you don't get
[ __ ] any juice out of that [ __ ] and I
was like let me just squeeze the [ __ ]
lemon the way I want to squeeze the
[ __ ] lemon I forget that's how much
our lemon I want
big ass tacos were stupid it was like to
drive it's a bigger circle anyway I just
watched him pick up lemon wedge put it
over the taco
[ __ ] like slowly go do and then set it
down and I was just sitting there like
why the [ __ ] did you even do that
like you're not [ __ ] no no it's a city
yeah it's just like that's how you
squeeze lemons you didn't even put it in
Lent like let it hop over yeah bro my
tongue to acid hurts so yeah I mean we
just kind of I oh he just like slam the
table and then he's just like I did it
you always [ __ ] nitpicking me for
everything and I was just like I just
thought it was funny but you squeeze one
little do taco it's like when they have
as I say add a little person jumps into
the pool just yeah that's so [ __ ]
funny man but that's like that's what
I'm saying you don't know how close you
are to somebody until you figure out how
much they can piss you off
yeah then you're like oh I guess I'm
super annoyed like I'm like how do we
get past being annoyed that's hard
because I know i annoy the [ __ ] out of
me give it some time could you think
about that situation it's pretty [ __ ]
yeah that situation is ridiculous and
also the taco the what was at the KFC
one the chicken the fried chicken one do
you remember the fried chicken day where
we went to like three different places
trying to get fried chicken and he wound
up leaving me I left her at a KFC in
Compton no it was it was I know where
Compton is it was content Boulevard or
whatever the [ __ ] no there's no Compton
Boulevard it was what was it cuz it on
the street from Gus's fried chicken
you know cuz that's like well sure yeah
it's basically his hood there though
yeah what's the name of that street
though it's a famous street I know what
you're talking I know where that is
that's just that areas ghetto yeah yeah
so I was just like you're gonna [ __ ]
leave me here you don't care yeah she
left me she left the car she almost look
like Oh didn't I drove I drove away
then you guys have fights like my
parents did that's how my parents would
fight you know I
I know her so much I knew a media is
just gonna call uber so I just made sure
that she had her phone and I'm like yeah
she has her phone and then I know she
was gonna call uber I missed that chaos
he's still making sure that you're okay
he goes [ __ ] you [ __ ] goes that's how I
know I still love her do like I'll be in
Japan so you drive away I was like this
[ __ ] don't love me that's how I
wanted you to feel when we were in Japan
this is how I know I [ __ ] love her
right cuz like we're in Japan
and I'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
irritating me right yeah all right and
then I look over and I'm like thank God
my mom's talking to her right now
I hope my mom talks about good things
with their and they bond like such an
interesting dynamic man like you know
when I see like your guys problem like I
never like I don't think I've ever seen
like something where I'm just like a
hand you guys find a lot but there's
always like effort yeah I mean like I
always look into something like effort
when I see somebody stop trying it's
when I get worried you know when I see
that that that that willingness to try
to make something work it just
disappears and you're just going in just
to go through the motions that's what
I'm just like this might be something
that that's a bit of an issue just
because I've seen now like I've man oh I
can't even count on my hands how many
people I know that got divorced you know
yeah and it I think the thing that I've
seen anyways and this is an anecdotal
thing is there's always somebody that
just stopped trying yeah I kind of feel
like maybe that's why we haven't gotten
engaged or married yet because we're
afraid that we might get divorced we're
kind of like mm is this gonna last so
we're kind of just putting it off I mean
that's a good thing to think about
though I mean even even hearing that
it's actually kind of healthy because
most people will just bury that [ __ ]
yeah and maybe the ring will make it
happier whatever like I think we're very
honorable in a way where we do not
commit and give our word unless it means
something and we can be a hundred
percent confident that that's what I
really truly feel so hmm some people
might feel pressured because everyone
else around them is doing it imagine if
a friend got engaged or something like
that right that would make us feel
pressured and maybe that social pressure
would make us just do it because we feel
like we're falling behind but I don't
[ __ ] play by those rules yeah I I
just genuinely want to be with someone
that I know that I'm not gonna make the
same mistakes my parents do and get a
divorce and all that stuff because I
really I think we hold our words very
highly because she's very committed like
she doesn't even commit to two
brainstorming ideas I mean but that's
because it's like I don't want to go
forth and give a promise that I can't
fulfill you know so of course you got to
give some type of slack when you're
thinking about that kind of stuff cuz
it's not nothing gonna be perfect right
but I think that's where we connect
because I have this feeling that she
wants to feel right about it I want to
feel right about it and it's not that
it's wrong I want to be sure that we can
be a couple that can figure it out and
be at peace you know yeah I think we're
for a long time we're still in the thing
we're still thinking of like saying I do
as like I say I do too have any Harris
[ __ ] stories over and over and over
again he's like I'm gonna have to say I
do to hear you [ __ ] and complain about
everything even the food we're eating
today and then I like so we're not
seeing it as I say I do - loving you or
seeing it as I say I do - like all this
[ __ ] that's like it is until we feel
comfortable with that and can fully
accept it I don't think we can get
married right yeah there's no balance
yeah so we need the balance to accept
the faults of each other yeah so I think
man it's it's it's awesome because I was
telling her like it sucks that we're
fighting it sucks that we get into these
negative ruts right but the awesome
thing about it is if I had to do this
with anyone I'm glad it was with you
because you're the only person that's
strong enough to deal with my craziness
yeah you're the only person that's
patient enough to deal with you know all
of the insanity that I have and if I
didn't have you to be my mirror to help
me grow out of all the issues that I
have like I'm not sure anybody else
would mm-hmm you know it's hard to find
that person you're gonna have to record
I think we had that recording because
you might have put that in vows
hahaha that's some good [ __ ] yeah that's
it's hard yeah I mean it's like like I
said I mean you guys seem to have like
all the pieces you know I mean it's just
a matter of is it strong enough to where
you guys can pull that trigger I think
it's for me it's like we have the pieces
we don't have the self-control yeah so
that our impulses in autopilot is really
[ __ ] bad yeah so the habits are
really bad so ultimately we both want
the same thing which is the love and the
happiness and the butterflies and all
that good [ __ ] right and just getting
along and being at peace and whatever
but that stillness doesn't exist because
I think we just have baggage from past
and all kinds of stuff whatever it is
and then the habits we're just having a
hard time breaking those habits yeah and
you know like I mentioned before you
guys grew up in just very harsh
households so we know that foundation is
it's so important and I you know we just
never knew how important it was until
you guys have this now yeah you know so
that like I said conflict resolution may
didn't get to see that a lot you know
what I mean I mean you talked about your
personal life on your channel you guys
could go watch on her channel she just
goes into her whole life especially with
her mother like it was it was pretty
insane growing up for you you know so
now it's just a matter of like you know
are you guys gonna be the first ones to
break that cycle yeah and it's just I
feel like sometimes things are just so
extreme like we we make things extremely
doesn't have to be yeah right so how we
deal with things that are just that
normally should just make you irritated
goes to anger yeah you know and that's
the scary part that I see a lot is like
okay this person did that and they go
what the [ __ ] it's like and that's the
thing that Mariel says to me sometimes I
had to say to her I go your reaction was
not appropriate for what just happened
here you know so me leaving this me
leaving a Dookie stain in the toilet
isn't enough for you to come out and say
the whole world is gonna burn do you get
in trouble for leaving Dookie sticky
stains in the toilet that's what
you know yeah like why would you yeah
dude one time I literally I had to
record it in my phone because of how
that a killer she was being and I was
laughing at her the whole time cuz she
goes she goes are you serious
like what happened she goes there's a
poop stain in my toilet and I was like
was it your she goes it's not mine it's
yours I'm so sick of this I was like
hold on a second I need you to backtrack
you're here you should be here yeah I
was like I understand that the poop
stain made you mad but you're yelling
yeah yeah and I'm like honest it's not
on the couch you know obviously she
starts laughing after a while because
she realize how ridiculous it is this is
just like pouting throughout the whole
thing and I was like your response for
the poop is too high some other show
it's something else you know so we
always we do we do this thing where we
go response is not right like be angry
but be angry here you don't be angry
here be angry here if you're angry here
that I have to match that level yeah cuz
I don't want to match that energy over a
poop stain yeah now I'm just gonna look
back at me like that was the dumbest
[ __ ] argument yeah now I just have to
be like okay dude David don't get mad
she's just being stupid you know cuz
then she does that for me to like let me
tell you this thing this my fault I have
a thing where if for example I'm a
relatively clean guy but when I had to
move out of the office and move stuff in
here I had to figure out how to make
this tiny space work but because they
wouldn't work in my head right I started
freaking the [ __ ] out like I was walking
around the house and this is gonna be a
lot of f-bombs by the way I was just
walking up with [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] break this
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] break this desk ass
like a [ __ ] Fitness [ __ ] stupid
ass [ __ ] place she goes petting me
like a pet I'm gonna [ __ ] touch me
right now and we [ __ ] petted [ __ ]
[ __ ] dropping all over the place and
then finally she goes do you know what
this is what we're gonna do we'll get a
tape measure if it fits it'll fit watch
it's gonna fit oh that's not [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] here okay and then lo
and behold it fit and then I calm down
she goes well don't you think you're
acting really stupid yeah and I'm like
because I was just dropping f-bombs for
a solid like 30 minutes for no reason
and I'd even get out of tape measures
and just measure it out so you know it's
really cute but like the problem we have
I think is like all everyone does that
stuff right but every single time one of
us has an episode or we fight we like we
kind of hate each other a little bit
more and we never forgive each other for
it so like I would never forgive Joe if
he did that and like I would still be
just it's just like it takes down our
image of the other person and so we
never forget every single time there's
something that blew up yeah I think so
how do you guys feel after the argument
you kind of laugh about it and it's over
right it is over we don't she doesn't
hate you for that effort no absolutely
not because what happens is is that I
after that after we had this episode and
I act stupid I also we also end with an
understanding that there's a commitment
that I'm gonna try not to do that again
then I'm gonna get a little bit better
even by centimeters or inches it doesn't
matter maybe it's one less [ __ ] than the
30 right so we make a commitment to try
not to do this so another example is
like we talked about how when we get
angry coming up in a household with a
lot of anger punching [ __ ] breaking [ __ ]
yeah she should be fine with this story
so we we had a fight here where I had
this little cream thing that I was
holding right and I can't remember what
exactly it was but it would it boiled
down to was it in my household they
always hated lying and arguably for me
because I don't like lying so much maybe
I'm like too honest so because I used to
get my ass [ __ ] beat if I lied and
you know I grew up in a Christian
household so the only time I would lie
is if like I had I snuck out of the
house but if it was something I [ __ ]
up on I just arguably just told the
truth so I wouldn't get beat up more
yeah and so that's been ingrained in my
head and I think I get burned a lot for
that because I tell everything about
myself every little [ __ ] thing I tell
about myself because it's almost like a
fear of what do I have to hide if I hide
admit it's gonna be worse so with her
she has this thing where she was saying
that she was upset she wasn't upset but
she was talking to me very
disrespectfully and I I just kind of
told I was like well when you're mad at
me like do you
be mad but when you say sorry say it
correctly don't don't say sorry like
that because when you do that it it's it
makes me feel like you're believable
Italy maybe you think I'm dumb so when
you apologize say it wholeheartedly cuz
I always do that for you she goes I am
saying you wholeheartedly and then she's
lying to me and I grew up in a household
where life wasn't acceptable so it's
boiling this anger inside me I was like
hey I told you you could do whatever you
want just don't lie to me
right and she goes I'm not lying what
else do you want me you want me to like
grovel blah blah blah and then you know
that anger Saavedra big I rather hear
I'm not ready to say sorry exactly yeah
so I rather hear that say hey give me
some space and then let's solve it later
but she was so emotionally charged at
the time which is understandable because
we're fighting but to me I just heard
lie lie lie and that's what I grew up
with I used to get beat for that [ __ ] so
I hate lying that's why I'm even
learning to white lie now right so like
she kept doing that and a gun I got me
that's so [ __ ] angry and you know
childhood [ __ ] I had the small little
[ __ ] CBD cream and I chucked it and
it shattered everywhere and when it
shattered
she went into a room to the bathroom and
she started crying mm-hmm and at that
moment I stopped being angry and the
reason why I stopped being angry is
because knowing the fact that I did
something to scare her and make her cry
made me feel terrible and so since then
we had a conversation I asked her I go
well she came out and she wipes her
tears away and I and I looked at her
almost like stupid I was like why are
you crying
and she goes I'm crying because you
scared me I was like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] hit you what do you what are you
talking about and she goes it doesn't
matter if you're not gonna hit me which
she was when I was a kid when my parents
would get angry or something you know in
a Korean household I would see my father
get angry but I wanted to be a strong
girl so I didn't show him that I was
scared but I can't do that with you so
for me I just had to run away and cry
because you scared me I know you're not
gonna hit me but you scared me and the
energy and it's just the that kind of
exposure you know as she goes I see you
doing that
if we have kids I see you breaking stuff
in kids I see you doing that and then
our kids pick it up just like you did so
what do we do here
and so for me now I know I know that's a
baseline thing first so now I know that
whenever we fight even if I get angry I
just have to walk away but I can
we'll never shatter anything in front of
her ever again so she doesn't hold that
against me I haven't broke anything in a
while it's been a minute you know so
those are the things that I have to
figure out and then she's not gonna hold
it against me because I broke this
little cream she's gonna say she's gonna
trust me to say he's gonna do his best
not to do that again and I happen but
then when you do it again the trust goes
away right a bit but yeah you know let's
say I didn't do it but we fought let's
say we fight I don't know we haven't
fought since then but let's we fight six
times since then
right but within that six times I broke
something once so I didn't do it every
time so I got better mm-hmm so she has
to look for those things of okay we're
not recognizing the little baby steps
yes there are there is progress guys
have a lot of when I when I sit down and
just think about the progress when we're
not mad at each other
there's a lot of progress yeah but when
we're upset at each other it's it's just
that it's that after a moment it's that
post mortem were you thinking about it
and you go well and not not to the point
where you're making excuses for somebody
but you're really seeing the effort you
know an effort to me means everything
because that shows that you care that
you're trying and if you're if I think
if you're in a healthy relationship you
want that person to be better because
you guys make each other better and I do
see it a lot in both of you number one
you've changed a lot since you came here
to I think like you know just to bring
it back to what we were first talking
about you moving here was something very
difficult and you were very closed off I
think it's because number one us as a
group synergistically we just worked so
well it was hard for you to blend in
with us yeah you know your sense of
humor I'll be it was my sense of humor
so I think that's why we got along very
well and you know I'm not very sensitive
like that so it kind of made sense but
for you it kind of just you were just
forced into a situation that was very
harsh yeah I did I definitely didn't fit
in right away yeah and I think I wasn't
used to large groups of people too so it
was always me and like one or two other
girls and like that was my circle and I
was kind of maybe the Alpha in the
circle so then coming then now into a
group full of alphas who are already
super close and there's a bunch of you I
just threw me way off and I was just
super uncomfortable like for a long time
yes your way at least we're almost like
two of the four years that I was
it was it was difficult to feel like I
fit in for sure yeah and you know we we
ball I mean people don't ever get to see
the the behind the scenes stuff either
and even for you because I know that
when you came here you had an idea of
what we were because you saw us on
videos you know and I and I think that
that image of what we were on those
videos kind of already left you at a
disadvantage coming into this group and
in the video she watched we're like a
year old having barbecues and all that
she I'm in the middle of us being busy
as [ __ ] yeah and oh that's right you
came out so I like had seen JK I'd
watched a cave a little bit here and
there and like so I was like oh they're
like just shooting the [ __ ] like they're
having fun they're like chill and then
but then like when I get here it's just
like no one's hanging out everyone has
separate vlog channels everyone's doing
everything separately and it's just like
this year of the hustle and everything
like it wasn't what I what y'all like I
was seeing petraea cuz the year before
that was so [ __ ] fun because we spent
we did so much like barbecues and we
hung out and then I think that bonding
was set and then after was like cool we
have the relationship now let's get into
work mode you know cuz it it's like that
was already established like the
mentality was so different I think like
after a while too I started you know we
all realized it you know for me I
snapped you know but I started really
the one thing that helped me realize
that we were just doing this type of
behavior was obviously when you
mentioned it and also when I started
realized I had no more stories because I
wasn't going anywhere
yeah I was sitting here yeah and then
you know it became very apparent on JK
news weren't living yeah just cranking
out content and that's because I was
just like I was kind of sold this idea
right he's just like yeah we'll come in
like whatever and then like I'm seeing
the video so I'm like in my head I'm
like I'm expecting it to be one way and
then I get here and it's completely
different and there wasn't a lot of I
guess chances other than during dinner
for me to get too close to any to get
close to anyone so it just felt like it
took forever to like get through the
home I always tell people though you
come to [ __ ] mama so dude I think I
think for me like I understood the whole
hustle mentality but you know because
our hustle was also our fun so we never
had to
separate the two no I enjoyed it 24/7
you know working yeah ever felt like
work ever so it always just felt like we
were hanging out so we never had to put
that unit but we built so much this is
where I [ __ ] up
we built so much rapport and memories
together that it held us all of us we
don't we didn't need that but then I
didn't do a good job setting her up with
everybody in the group I thought she
would just hit the gun-running cuz she's
so smart she's so resourceful she's like
she could figure things out so fast yeah
I didn't know [ __ ] how socially
different she was like I didn't I didn't
even know she was like a social recluse
yeah I didn't know that because when I
was in Austin we would go and meet my
friends out there hang out go have
dinner whatever she's fine she's talking
to everybody whatever I didn't know that
there were gonna be this well it's like
huge it's different situations though
it's like smaller groups it's like a
double date or something of because you
know like one guy and his girlfriend and
awesome yeah and I was blind to that
because I'm so social I don't I don't
see the difference whether it's one
person or 3,000 you know like it's I
mean you're very different and Bart in
that sense you you you're you could your
social butterfly yeah you could mold I
could maneuver like yes whatever yeah
and plus like regular people in Austin
are different from like LA youtubers oh
it's a different totally different like
the more willing your the willingness to
like allow new people to come in it's a
lot different because like regular
people will meet regular people but then
like youtubers are kind of like oh
they're a little bit more like I don't
know standoffish with newcomers I feel
like and this group definitely did that
to me too mmm-hmm not me you did a
little maybe a little bit but you
chilled out the fastest towards me
here's my thing was like I didn't know
anything about you
right and so I think it's a two-way
street I always felt for me like so how
I am as a person I'm pretty sure people
know about this when I make a connection
with somebody I keep somebody for
[ __ ] life you have to do something
pretty bad to me for me to say [ __ ] off
to you right so even with TIFF when tip
first came to this group I didn't know
who the [ __ ] she was multiple times
because I didn't know how long she was
gonna last and I didn't want to commit
myself to somebody only to have him
leave yeah so when you first came around
I was just gonna let the group feel you
out first and
I would just kind of like okay she's
gonna stick around so let me invest some
time into her because at that point it
was I didn't know if you were gonna
stick around and yeah me neither
yeah and TIFF was hard to beat son of a
catch-22 though cuz it's like everyone's
kind of like well is she even gonna be
here is it worth our time but then it
like makes it harder yeah and then for
me too because I had the same feeling
towards other people I'm like well
should I even bother getting close to
David and bard and geo and SIF and all
these people if I'm just gonna leave
anyways you know so it was like it was
you guys moved in together and you were
living when I kind of figured all you're
they're living together and [ __ ] you
know I didn't because I didn't know that
off the bat either yeah so I was like oh
well you know and then and it's also
weird too I think because like I feel
like if maybe if I was a girl to be a
lot easier right no really you don't
think so no she makes friends with guys
like Val really fast I like women it's
just a lot more complicated yeah and it
takes a lot longer yeah to be like hella
close she got I think closer with you
and Steve way quicker than any of the
girls but that's the that's true with a
lot of the girls you know like my girls
are very unique yeah they're they're not
very girly in that traditional sense of
where like girls [ __ ] rule a lot of
the girls in this group are very partner
connected so they hang out with their
partner and then if the partner hangs
out with somebody else then they'll do
it together right so I saw something
that I'm not really used to I think
that's the difference between me and I
think majority that JK people was that
Mariel has her own set of friends and I
have my own set of friends yeah y'all's
relationship is totally different yeah
compared to all of us yeah
and so I think but that's the part that
was a little not odd for me just because
when we had to make sure that we were
having friend time it was it was a
little more difficult cuz my doors are
always open like I always tell people
like you want to hang out come and hang
out like with Khalif or whatever he
texted me I'm like come on over let's
let's do something I just let Mariel
know I go hey Khalifa wants to hang out
today I'm gonna I'm gonna bounce is that
cool she goes I don't you have to ask
her I just told her it's gonna happen
yeah but you know I think because
everything once again it was so we were
so tied to our old memories we don't
need to do that no it's like I could not
see him for three years I'll pick it up
right where it left off yeah like
nothing ever happened but for you you
were a new person you didn't have that
rapport so it was a lot more difficult
than you know he was it was true we just
had barbecues all the [ __ ] all the time
we played basketball together we all
suck but we
three three four times a week we had
these like great moments where we
connected and bonded on a level level
that most people don't do in such a
short amount of time and I think you
didn't get to experience that yeah and
then we would be fighting over stuff
that because we were shocked that our
expectations weren't meeting reality so
we were fighting behind the scenes and
then I come eat dinner with all y'all
and then I'm already like well [ __ ] this
whole what the hell's wrong with Jen and
I was like she's invited me and I'm like
man it's so weird like why don't you
like my friends yeah that's weird cuz I
like I liked everyone I saw everyone on
on YouTube before I met them and I was
like all these people seem cool like
j.lo seem cool or whatever but then
matter and person I was like so I can
say that a lot in public but yeah yeah
that's so interesting because people
don't know like this perspective behind
just what they see on the screen like
even for you you feel victim to that you
know I think hopefully I'm almost the
exact same person I'm on screen maybe
just a lot I think you're better and
realise that you are on screen honestly
I like hanging out with you but then at
some of these other people in the group
at the beginning I was like god I wish I
just never met them because I liked them
on video and that was it it's really cuz
um I don't know maybe it's because like
like I said like I've always been the
type of person in the group and even
Mariel notices about me she always
mentions it she goes people warm up to
you fast you know is either people hate
me or they really it depends on if I
like that you know so she goes when you
like somebody she goes they could sense
how much you like them yeah you know you
dislike them the whole universe feels it
yeah it's like boom like you completely
just shut them out like they don't exist
like she's even seen me like some people
what's up I go I just like walked past
them cuz I don't wanna say anything mean
yeah you know you're very strong
emotionally yeah yeah it's just like I
just um I think it's because you know
when you get burned when you're younger
I just don't like to waste time with
people anymore
if I like you I'm not afraid to express
how much I like you if I respect you I'm
not afraid to express how much I respect
you and I'll just leave it at that why
even hide it at this point but once
again the other side is if I [ __ ]
dislike you the Udrih you will [ __ ]
feel it you know I'm not gonna go I'm
gonna call you an [ __ ] but you could
tell when a spawning at everybody you
say something mean I don't laugh at once
not once Jews like that yeah that's
probably what it is geo and I actually
had this thing where it's funny because
we dislike the same people and then we
just I'll just look at her she goes yup
I'm like yep I already know what you're
saying I hate that person yeah y'all are
like smizing to each other across the
room well I'm sitting there as a new
girlfriend - Joe - and I'm like oh let's
see them smizing to each other
I don't you you're fine now I am I think
like I did I never felt any bad way
towards you though like I didn't think
that there was anything cuz once again I
never spent as much time with you
because I'm I'm JK honorary member I
still got my own thing yeah and then I
would come into the mix after and then
you know I what hear you speak about
what you're going through and then the
group would talk about how things just
aren't messing well and then I start
picking up pieces a little bit and I'm
like yeah I could see like how our
attitude can be bad then I talk to you
and I can see how you think there'd
being this way - so it all kind of made
sense and it's just like I said you were
thrown into something that was very hard
for you to meld it yeah it was not a
good idea but I did it and I think it
made me stronger and now I feel like I
could be thrown into a lot more
situations with a better idea of how to
handle myself so it was worth it I guess
yeah you needed it yeah just the way I
needed you to make me angry
he actually I think out of all the JK
people changed the most in the past uh
like just seven or eight years like the
first time I've seen him till now he's
but he's actually like a 180 mm-hmm like
number one emotionally on like
emotionally an empathy are the two
things that I think that you've changed
the most empathy is something that
you've gained maybe not to like the
normal standard but like you do and you
do and you do have it you do have a lot
of empathy and you also understand how
to assess a situation from a less
emotional state because I think like
when you were first you were such an
excitable human being that everything
was just Spartan
man I was telling my I forgot who else
on the other day but I I don't I used to
live life without thinking hmm
everything was just feeling yeah and I
don't even remember a lot of things that
I did I'm just living in the moment yeah
and I thought a lot but about things
that didn't matter it was not internal
it was about politics [ __ ] philosophy
or whatever I'm reading [ __ ] right yeah
and I'm just going down the rabbit hole
of information but I'm just a constant
impulse yeah so I I was ruled by my
feelings man I just did whatever the
[ __ ] I wanted yeah and I don't know I
think there's good in in that where I
got to where I am today cuz I'm not
thinking and I'm not living by my fear
or anything I just do it but also if I
don't self reflect I don't grow you know
and if I'm not aware of the situation
it's like I'm just living in a [ __ ]
dream right but I'm not taking into
considerations of what what's going on
the dynamic yeah so that's kind of like
oh [ __ ] I had to figure that out because
it especially with her I'm like oh my
reality is not her reality yeah I mean
how do you feel like you've changed a
lot yes you moved here I think I may be
more conscious of how I'm coming across
like even though I still have like kind
of [ __ ] face a lot and I complain a lot
I I'm a hundred percent more aware of
like how I'm projecting myself and my
energy into a room that was a big thing
because use it I used to be the same way
like I wasn't really thinking about like
how my energy was spilling out into the
world around me and now I'm obviously
there's cameras on me and there's people
telling me things about myself and
there's comments so like I'm more a
little bit more aware of that hmm
but emotionally I don't know if I've
changed that much emotionally I think
I'm about the same really yeah do you I
mean I guess like for me I guess from
like an outside perspective I think like
maybe you don't see it but I see it is
more like I think you're more honest
with yourself because having having that
ability to say like okay
people do see me a certain way even
though that I don't feel it is some you
learning how to be honest with yourself
yeah it's like oh maybe I don't really
know myself as well as I thought I did
yeah
so that's that's a huge thing I think
that's some [ __ ] that I struggle with
all the [ __ ] time like I said I was
[ __ ] fat like I know people think is
a joke I didn't [ __ ] know because I
would see myself in the mirror and I'm
like I still got these bits she's like
what about that belly just looking from
here but this is the problem you know
what guys know how to compartment like
any well yeah we're just like mmm that
nipple looks nice and circular you don't
have to see the beauty in [ __ ]
garbage yeah I know how to see the
garbage and beauty listening to this
[ __ ] like on the way here and it was
about controlling your outlook on life
and negative emotions right and they're
saying how Mother Teresa she would like
go down India and she's like she sees
all these dead [ __ ] bodies right yes
he's like people sick people begging she
sees all this [ __ ] right and then she
sees a piece of [ __ ] on the floor and
out of that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
there's a flower growing out of it that
was her that was her pivotal moment when
that moment was when she was like oh I'm
able to like see the beauty in all of
this disaster yeah what other good is
there in the world oh wow and then so
I'm like that's either so [ __ ]
optimistic to the point where your
delusional [ __ ] or that's something
that's a skill like to be able to defuse
that when skill dude because when people
are getting shot up and dying around you
and you're still like there's something
beautiful about this you know or
something good that still exists in the
world that's something that's like I
wish I had that power I don't have that
power I just more like give in to the
[ __ ] I might you have my car exploded
today like it's so bad like even the
other day I got hit I got rear-ended
like going to the [ __ ] sit meeting
and I was just like
all right I just gotta let it go because
there's like a scratch of the dead and I
was like Mike it's a Honda Element and
the guy looked at me who just goes he
goes I'll pay for a site for what why
bother dudes I'm gonna fight it yeah
just go away kind of that's kind of
reminding me of this thing so this book
I'm reading it's called everything is
[ __ ] by Mark Manson and he talks about
this concept of a more fatty it's like a
Frederick Nietzsche thing that he came
up with it's like the love of one's fate
so like you're just kind of like going
through life just acceptance yeah it's I
haven't fully grasped it concept of it
but it's a really interesting thing like
that and I think a lot of people should
kind of look it up and read into it but
it's just like the love of your fate
it's like your if it's good or if it's
bad or whatever it's like you're
accepting all of it because all of it is
life so that you can't run from getting
hit in the car like you know you can't
run running family death you can't run
from hurt you can't run from a lot of
pain right and in that same pump you see
that I was listening to they were saying
like okay so these things is just a part
of life but the more you try to fight it
and deny it
the bigger it becomes I mean you gotta
just experience it that's just so [ __ ]
you just gotta go through with it but
then not have a judgement on it when you
start judging it is when it starts
becoming this thing where you obsess
about it and I [ __ ] like that I've
been I mean I guess I feel like I invoke
something like that to just not in as
like xvi is that but that's you know we
talk about all the time we go
that's [ __ ] life it's just life why
you [ __ ] so I don't know you know
yeah we talk about people who wallow in
their own sadness because something bad
happens it will prolong it yeah that's
been me for most of my life I've been
very nihilistic person and that's why I
have that kind of dark energy and that's
I guess if we're gonna say how I've
changed the most and how you're saying
being honest with yourself that's how
I'm being more honest with myself and
like recognizing recognizing that I
carry a dark cloud and I'm just like oh
everything sucks and I'm like you know
I'm like in a black-and-white vintage
film with a cigarette like some sad ass
music did you get was so damn happy you
should've got with a goth guy or some
[ __ ] I know I should pay less rocker we
would have gotten along a lot better
problem I know you two could have sat in
the corner talk [ __ ] all day yeah I
literally just picked you with that long
cigarette and this [ __ ] do just
walking one so what are you doing there
pretty lady the world spinning yeah I
mean do you feel like I mean why do you
think you don't like that though I mean
that's a Jedi no why she's like I mean I
guess just the abandonment that I face
as a child just made me like sad and
feel like there's you know life sucks
and all that and I just never grew out
of it so I think that's the I haven't
reached level of maturity to grow out of
that like adolescent would you
accomplish so I mean let's let's move
off she does JK like you she's a [ __ ]
master she doesn't ever read her self
and she's never if you notice she never
boasts about the [ __ ] that she's done
yeah when she should because you should
be proud that you [ __ ] your uprooted
your whole life yeah you're the fertile
you are you that you're the only one out
of your family that's basically going to
college her parents didn't go to college
or and she got a master's degree right
she had a higher high position and an
accounting firm you know like and you
brought yourself yourself out of poverty
no one put her through school she was
she put herself through school you know
like loans the government brought me
through yeah she's not like this
privileged ass white girl that's like
everything's [ __ ] none of that stands
out because everyone yes but it's a
median level of accomplishment so I
don't think that yes you're not Mike
Tyson what you know what like it is a
struggle that you did and you won and no
matter how insignificant that might
sound it's still big to a lot of people
so you got to remember like put yourself
in a
in your shoes when you were in poverty
and you're [ __ ] living on food stamps
and [ __ ] and someone told you you're
gonna get a master's degree would you be
like yeah right or when you're [ __ ]
doing drugs and then you're like being a
bunch you know with a bunch of [ __ ]
and [ __ ] yeah cuz I don't think that's
common it's not because I grew up with a
lot of poor people I even think about I
I do I thought about this the other day
wasn't my car just randomly like I
thought about my best friend right now
he's a [ __ ] doctor like I don't know
I just hit me in my head and I was like
my best friend's a [ __ ] doctor that's
so weird and even though there's a lot
of doctors in the world yeah it's still
something that's like wow you worked
[ __ ] hard for that yeah that's
something that yes everyone can do it if
they put their mind to but it's still
hard yeah and you got to own you got to
own it like we're both poor ass [ __ ]
kids and he's a doctor
like I'm partial in four [ __ ]
businesses now like I've had my you know
he's a doctor like I couldn't get that
out of my head and I don't know if it's
hit if it hits him like that but he's
very grateful over the position that
he's in but anybody could say like you
said yeah there's a lot of doctors in
this world very true but when I look at
his situation what he had to go through
to get there it's nobody would have
thought nobody would think she's too
Asian dude that's why God you know it's
like it's not a brain surgeon yeah you
just like sitting there just beating
yourself up like anybody could've got a
masters and not me
that's for sure I barely read yes it's
not so much like boasting about it like
I'm proud this is how much I've done
because it's literally yeah you ain't
[ __ ] cuz a lot of people have masters
right but at the point is I got this far
imagine how much further I can get yeah
it's just something I got this far
despite you know all the obstacles that
I had I put myself through this you know
while I was working I didn't have any
help from anyone you know like that's a
part of I think that's like a big joy of
life though to accomplish something and
then really just appreciate yourself for
it like even something small like me
making that burger I'm so happy and
you're sharing your happiness they're
sharing your creation your creativity
yeah like even like that small thing
like when I made that burger and then I
ate it
and before I gave it to anybody else I
just thought to myself it's a [ __ ]
good burger dude like I was shocked you
know and the first thing that I want to
do it like I wanna share it yeah I gave
it to Muriel first you know yeah I you
know I I ate it and then I gave us did I
make if I made for somebody else to came
through you guys and I'm like cool not
not everyone's addicted to it yeah and
we could that's gonna be the go-to BBQ
burger now did know now I know how I
want to make it and it's so simple it
makes me very happy
yeah a night I this is what I think why
she does is is because if you talk [ __ ]
to yourself no one can [ __ ] you up yeah
if you talk [ __ ] to yourself no one can
hurt you not only that if you already
expect the worst and it happens it
doesn't surprise you mmm so she it's
very kind can't ever fall from grace cuz
I'm already like six feet under you
can't drop me if I'm already sad [ __ ] I
can't follow what's wrong with your face
are you going comes you man I feel like
we could talk forever but you know time
is up on the polygon I should I
Wow I didn't even know there was a timer
up there yeah what that that it doesn't
to conclude this episode as we keep
going but I feel like we just got
started to I know there's so much to
talk about I'm so not used to talking
like podcast style so I got to come back
and like I'm like I'm gonna get better
next time now you're doing great this is
awesome well guys like I said it doesn't
really conclude the episode but that's
this episode of the genius brain podcast
member catch us on Spotify if you are on
iTunes
give us that [ __ ] 5 star share it
with everybody
interact in the comments below and just
share and take us on your commute
because I feel like these conversations
just dopeman you just a fly on the wall
let's do a bunch of people talk their
[ __ ] get you know my personal life yeah
man but appreciate you guys man we have
been getting sponsorships and the more
you guys share it the more we can
continue to do these so our burgers
David can make
for everybody so I mean just where can
they find you I have my own channel it's
just my name Jessica Caldwell there's
not it's not super active but there's a
few things on there they can check out
Instagram as well wishers dinner Jess
forgot my Instagram just underscore
Michelle five one two there we go yeah
catch right there well we'll see you
guys next time bye
toodaloo my ass